I mean nerves are good it's nerves are
different than um like fear that's
different nerves are more like
excitement and well my nerves are fear
okay that's different my my nerves are
fear too my nerves are excitement
usually unless I don't know the
song teror I'm not mine are usually
based I had this conversation with my
psychiatrist when I get nered he goes
well it's good everybody has nerves it's
this is I go no no I I need something
for this because it can be crippling
sometimes but do you find like an acting
like if you're really prepared like you
still get the nerve but it's it's a
different kind of nerve CU it's like you
you feel good if you're I feel like if
you're not prepared then it's becomes a
whole another set of nerve and I think
was being with these two guys helps me
helps a lot because they're they can be
calming too you know really you guys are
that calming cuz right now I feel they
help me a lot Robert's the calming
boy is he really yeah why why is Rob
Comming he's like hey man you know just
just play the song play the show just
focus on the song well what you what are
you saying before he says that are you
saying I'm like oh what the I'm
going to fail and what the
is is all wrong and I don't know